well it's been a prolific week for
privilege it All Began on Saturday with
a rousing Twitter debate about Anne
Frank's white privilege now apparently
some leftists on the platform had been
discussing the issue of inherent
privileges allegedly enjoyed by victims
of the Holocaust and TMZ was the first
Outlet to pick up on this conversation
and report on it with the breathless and
only semi-coherent headline Anne Frank
she had white privilege Twitter debates
TMZ reports in their article Twitter is
yet again proving it's the worst for
bulk bad takes this time debating
whether Anne Frank who was hunted and
killed by Nazis had white privilege
while alive and there's an emoji I don't
even know what that emoji is supposed to
mean they put it in the middle of like a
news article an emoji
then they continue you might have
noticed that uh the the late Holocaust
victim was trending Saturday but finding
out why is disheartening some it seems
have floated an argument that Frank
benefited from White Privilege in Nazi
Germany an argument that is rightly
being shot down left and right unclear
how this toxic discourse first started
but it seems to stem from a warped
notion that Jews had the benefit of
their skin color to go unnoticed in
public if only temporarily during that
Bleak time in history while POC uh
historically haven't been able to do so
the theory is so twisted and yet it's
being defended by a select few on the
Bird app
now as always
the first thing that jumps out of you
anytime you read a TMZ article is that
the film idiocracy had it wildly wrong
because in the movie it took 500 years
for the world to be so completely dumbed
down and stupefied that a guy with an IQ
of 95 is the greatest genius on the
planet by all appearances we'll reach
that point probably in another I don't
know you know not 500 years maybe 500
minutes or so
as for the White Privilege debate
um TMZ may be scandalized by the very
notion that a 16 year old girl who died
in the Holocaust could be accused of
having you know any kind of privilege at
all
and it is an incredibly stupid idea but
it's also what leftism teaches the
doctrine of white privilege clearly
states that white people possess
inherent privileges on the basis of
their race no exceptions Are Made for
This or can be made because any
exception would unravel the whole idea
of inherent privilege to begin with if
any individual white person can lose
their privilege or never possess it to
begin with it would prove that privilege
is not something automatically bestowed
on everyone based on skin pigmentation
and if that's the case then the white
privilege Creed is invalid but the
invalidation of the white privilege
concept would mean the invalidation of
the less entire racial project which
they can't allow to happen this means
that all white people everywhere in all
situations must be indicted for
possessing inherent privilege no matter
how invisible that privilege may seem
Holocaust victims had privilege uh the
white child born in a single wide
trailer to a meth addicted mother has
privilege the homeless white guy
sleeping under the bridge bridge has
privilege
the white college applicant denied
Acceptance in favor of a less qualified
minority applicant has privilege
if you are whites
even if you can find no evidence in your
life that you were ever given any
advantage because of your race and even
if on on the contrary there's actually
evidence that you've been disadvantaged
because of your race you still have
privilege
privilege is unfalsified there is
nothing you can do to disprove it and
that includes being murdered in the
Holocaust
if that sounds crazy to you well yes
exactly you're getting the point
but there are more developments on the
privilege front this weekend a tick tock
video went viral thanks to our friend
Libs of tick tock featuring
an obese woman explaining the concept of
thin privilege
yes privilege is not just a signed on uh
based on race of course there are many
other forms of it as Tick Tock user gay
DHD goddess explains listen
I
have thin privileged
but I'm so fat I'm like a size 20 22.
how can I possibly have thin privilege
because there are people who are fatter
than me when I go up on a plane I might
need a seatbelt extender I might be
uncomfortable I may not feel good people
may say things to me
but I don't need to buy a second seat or
risk getting kicked off the plane
that means that I have privilege
compared to people who have that
experience
you may not even need a seatbelt expand
extender if that's the case then you
have privilege compared to me
somebody who is a model size may have
privilege compared to you
but that doesn't mean you don't have any
privilege
almost all of us have some thin
privilege it's a spectrum and it goes by
degrees
right if you need a seat belt extender
you still have thin privilege because at
least you fit into one C she says
she actually says that and if you need
two seats you still have thin privilege
compared to somebody who takes up the
whole row and that person actually has
thin privilege compared to somebody who
needs to Charter their own military
cargo plane just to get around and that
person has thin privilege compared to
somebody who can't fly at all and has to
be tied down to an aircraft carrier like
King Kong and dropped off on a mythical
Island filled with other Prehistoric
Beasts and as long as there's at least
one other life form theoretically more
gargantuan than you
you have thin privilege we're told
now you can kind of see that the
self-serving I would really call it
Brilliance of the thin privilege
Spectrum concept because all at once it
allows the fat person to claim victim
status you know competing for gold in
the oppression Olympics while at the
same time rationalizing their gluttony
by also claiming fin status in
comparison to people fatter than
themselves
so they can have their cake and eat it
too in their case both figuratively and
I'm sure literally the magic of
intersectional victimology all at one
all at once makes them both victims of
fatness and beneficiaries of Fitness
they can be both
it's the best of both worlds or at least
it would be if the world's actually
existed but they don't
because as a great philosopher once said
I think it was Aristotle uh he said uh
quoting he said the mere existence of a
fatter ass does not make your ass any
less fat
thinness you know may have a relative
component to it for example
even after gorging myself on vacation
for a week and a half I am still thinner
than let's say a humpback whale
but that doesn't really mean anything
because if you're a human being your
thinness or fatness is judged really not
based on a comparison between yourself
and other species or even between
yourself and other people but rather on
how a human is supposed to be built
the problem with being fat is that if
you are fat
you are carrying around more lard than
your body was made to handle and that
would be the case even if you were the
only person on Earth
even if if you are morbidly obese and
everyone else dies and you're the last
person living you would still be fat
because your body wasn't made to handle
all that fat you're over taxing your
bones your internal organs you're
killing yourself that would be the case
no matter what else what anybody else is
doing
this is also why thin privilege makes no
sense
no matter what the left has tried to do
with the word privilege is quite simply
as the dictionary still defines it at
least for now
a special right advantage or immunity
granted or available only to a
particular person or group that's a
privilege
the ability to fit onto an airplane seat
is not a special right or Advantage the
ability of my liver and lungs and other
internal organs to function normally
is not a special right or Advantage it's
simply the standard Human Experience
it's what we're supposed to all
experience the obese person has
inflicted upon himself special
disadvantages
let us make him a victim in any kind of
societal sense of the term
the same can be can be applied to the
concept of racial privilege
if you as a white person have never been
explicitly granted special rights or
advantages or immunities because of the
color of your skin then you don't have
white privilege
okay if there if there is um nothing
that you're like allowed to do because
you're white that other non-white people
aren't allowed to do if then then you
don't have white privilege
you might have other privileges
there are indeed privileges that come
with let's say being wealthy
uh there are privileges that come with
being extremely attractive
not that I would know is especially the
case if you're a woman all kinds of
privileges come with being an attractive
woman
and most of all there are privileges
granted on the basis of ideology
you you will enjoy the support and
encouragement of every powerful
institution in the country if you're on
the left side of the ideological divide
that's the greatest privilege that our
society has to offer
it's where true privilege can be found
in many ways
so ironically those complaining about
their lack of privilege are doing so in
order to gain privilege
by professing the doctrine of privilege
they're publicly aligning themselves
with leftism and ensuring that they'll
be granted all the Privileges that come
with
and that is why
white privilege
and thin privilege and all the other
fallacious concepts of privilege are
today Cancer
I know you're uh craving some more Matt
Walsh show content while I have some
great news for you if you head over to
dailywire.com And subscribe now you can
watch or listen to my full show you can
also listen to my podcast on Spotify
Apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast I'll see you there